Good afternoon, everyone. Thank you all for being here.
I'm excited to start the chromosomal
instability educational session.
As many of you know, chromosomal instability is a hallmark of human
cancer, and really it is defined as
ongoing chromosome segregation errors every time cells divide.
Our normal cells have 46 chromosomes, obviously, and cell
division has to be very faithful. So chromosomal instability is one of
those features
that clearly distinguishes cancer cells from normal
cells. It's been known to be associated with poor prognosis and
aggressive cancer behavior for a very long time.
It's associated with metastasis, with therapeutic resistance,
and with cancer relapse. And it's usually a feature of
cancers that we think of in general as aggressive tumors.
For example, triple-negative breast cancer, pancreatic cancer,
brain tumors, ovarian cancer, et cetera.
And while we've appreciated the fact that chromosomal
instability is a driver of cancer progression, I think in the last
10 years, there has been a lot of effort by multiple groups, including
speakers from today, to try and translate
therapeutic strategies that tackle chromosomal instability in the clinic.
And so the session is really focused around two simple
concepts. What are the cell-intrinsic mechanisms or
approaches with which we can tackle chromosomal instability, and how our
understanding of aneuploidy that arises from chromosomal instability
creates these vulnerabilities?
And also, what are the cancer cell extrinsic or immune
mechanisms or approaches by which we can actually tackle chromosomal instability?
So our first speaker is going to be focused more on the cell-intrinsic component.
Our second speaker will be focused on the cell-extrinsic or immune component,
and I'll be presenting at the end with two
examples of how we can take that into the clinic, both cell-intrinsic example
and extrinsic. So without further ado, I would love to
introduce Professor Uri Ben-David from Tel Aviv University
to
talk to us about cell-intrinsic mechanisms of chromosomal instability.
Thank you.
Okay, so this being an educational session,
I decided that I would not focus on one specific study, but I would rather give
an overview of the concepts and
try to systematically review how we can target cell-intrinsic vulnerability of
unstable cancers and describe along the way some of our
contributions to the field. These are our disclosures.
So chromosomal instability drives cancer progression, and it does so in
various ways. First of all, of course, the mere instability
creates heterogeneity, and this heterogeneity
basically makes for the
substrate for evolution to work on.
But on top of that,
there are specific consequences of chromosomal instability that are
important for tumor development and progression.
So aneuploidy, which is the
change in the
copy number, number of entire chromosomes or chromosome arms being a very common
and very important one and is largely the focus of the work in my lab.
But we also have
chromothripsis, ecDNA, whole genome doubling, and then there are
epigenetic
consequences associated with these changes, and this we will hear later.
There are, of course, interactions with immune cells and so on.
So the consequence of chromosomal instability are the chromosomal catastrophes
which I've just
described. And I think that
in recent years we have had more and more evidence that actually
link these specific events
as bona fide drivers in specific context
of tumor development. Now, when we think about targeting chromosomal
instability, I think it's very important to
disentangle the process from the outcome.
So chromosomal instability is the process.
It's the increased rate of chromosome segregation, whereas
aneuploidy, as well as the other chromosomal catastrophes that I mentioned,
is basically the outcome of that.
And these specific
events that arise and get selected for can also
confer cellular stresses and may
also open the door for some therapeutic opportunities.
Now, when we think about targeting
the process, I think we can use the analogy from the mutation world, okay?
So if the specific
chromosomal consequences, like specific aneuploidies, would be similar
to a gene amplification, gene mutation that we
may be able to target with targeted therapies.
The process of chromosomal instability would be
similar to the, or analogical to the mutagenic process.
And so if you think about cancer therapeutics that take advantage, for example,
of targeting DNA damage repair and so on, this would be equivalent
to that. And I think it's important because often in the field, these terms tend to
be
mixed, and it's important to
understand what we're really talking about.
Now, it's also important to say that chromosomal instability and its consequences
are strongly correlated, but they are not the exact same thing.
Because you could think about scenarios where highly aneuploid
cells are no longer chromosomally unstable or on the
opposite,
which is that chromosomal instability may be ongoing, but no
specific karyotype would be
selected for, or the cells may have reached
an optimal karyotype for this specific tumor stage, at least, and these
specific selection pressures, and then there would be no further karyotypic
evolution. One example of that has recently been reported by the
Satoriva and Graham labs, and this is from a commentary that we
wrote on that paper, where they found that in
colorectal cancer, at some point, even though at the single-cell level, there's
still chromosomal instability, the karyotype remains
largely unchanged due to very strong negative
selection.So if we want to target the process,
how can we do that?
One option is to kill cancer cells by manipulating the CIN levels themselves.
So the idea here is that we have a optimal range of
chromosomal instability that is tolerated by the cells, but at the same
time enables them to adapt and to evolve.
Now, if we impair it, then we basically
prohibit
evolvability or adaptability. But if we also increase it too much
beyond a tolerated threshold, this can also
be used as therapeutics. And this is actually already going
in with a well-known and a
therapeutic. So for example, studies from Beth Weaver's lab have shown
that the way that Taxol works, at least in breast cancer
and in specific circumstances, is not by leading to
mitotic arrests, but rather by exacerbating the chromosomal
instability leading to more chromosomal
aberrations that are no longer tolerated by the cells.
Another way to target a chromosomally unstable cells is
to exploit the stresses that are induced by chromosomal instability.
So these stresses, this is from a review by Sam Becum.
Some of them are directly related to the process, and some are already related to
the consequence of this process. We can think about a
phototoxic stress, replication stress, metabolic stresses.
The idea here would be that these stresses in
non-malignant cells lead to apoptosis or cell cycle arrest
or senescence, and therefore chromosomal instability by
large is not tolerated in normal cells.
However, the cancer cells have
developed adaptation mechanisms or coping mechanisms, and so if we
target these coping mechanisms, we might be able to
make CIN
detrimental again.
And the same types of stresses are really what we see with
aneuploidy. So this is from a review that we wrote last year, and
I'm going to tell you a few stories about how
different types of stresses that are associated with aneuploidy can actually be
exploited to kill these
aneuploid cells simply by targeting the
mechanisms that these cells deploy to cope with
the aneuploid karyotypes. Now, in my lab, we apply experimental and
computational approaches to look into chromosomal instability and its
consequences. We take advantage of human primary tumor
data and patient-derived models, as well as human cancer
cell lines and systems of isogenic
cells that we and many collaborators of ours develop, where
we can look into the consequences of chromosomal instability or the
consequences of aneuploidy in an otherwise a
matched genetic background using
different types of isogenic systems.
Now,
when we think about targeting these consequences of aneuploidy, we also need
to distinguish two different types of
approaches. So one is to look at highly aneuploid tumors or highly
chromosomally unstable tumors and compare them to the diploid normal
cells. In this approach, we're trying to find synthetic lethalities
of the aneuploid state, regardless of the specific chromosome that is altered.
On the other side of the spectrum, as we know, there are specific
aneuploidies that are characteristic of specific cancer types
and are hallmarks of these specific tumors.
And if we identify vulnerabilities associated with these specific genetic
alterations, then this could be also valuable for
killing cells that harbor these genetic alterations.
So I will start by telling you a little bit about synthetic lethalities with
the aneuploid state, and I'll just mention kind of the
bottom lines of a few stories that are mostly
published related to these vulnerabilities.
So if we start with the cell cycle and the mitotic regulation, which is also, I
think, the case where really the aneuploidy and the CIN converge the
most because this is really vulnerability of CIN and aneuploid cells.
So a few years ago, we compared the genetic and
pharmacological sensitivities of highly aneuploid CIN
positive cell lines versus near diploid, relatively chromosomally
stable cell lines. And to make a long story short, we identified the
spindle chance assembly checkpoint and its regulator, KIF18A, as a
unique vulnerability of
chromosomally unstable aneuploid
tumor cells.
We
uncovered a part of the mechanism that leads to this.
There's still a lot that is currently ongoing.
And several groups reached to the same conclusion at the same
time. So Neil Ganem and Jason Stumpf's teams also identified
KIF18A as a vulnerability of chromosomally
unstable and
cells with different types of catastrophic chromosomal
alterations. And at the time, several
companies, Amgen, Valastra, and Akcea Therapeutics,
have been developing and are currently developing drugs to target
KIF18A.
These are in ongoing clinical trials.
First results were published by Valastra last year and raised a lot of
excitement in the field. I'm sure we will hear about it more in Sam's
talk later today. But this is already a case where I think we can see the
value and the therapeutic potential of this type of
approach. I just want to mention that last year, in
collaboration with Floys Fougere's team, we tried to go a bit deeper
into the cell cycle mechanism that enables the sensitivity to spindle assembly
checkpoint inhibitors. And we identified CDC20 as a key
regulator of the sensitivity to the inhibition of
the spindle assembly checkpointNow, more recently,
we
collaborated with Stefano Santaguida, and we wanted to take
this
one step further. So we generated isogenic,
non-transformed Rp1 cells with varied
levels of aneuploidy, and then we performed all the omics and all the functional
screening that we could do. And this is a resource that is also available for the
community. And that led us to two main discoveries.
One is related to DNA damage and repair.
So what we found was that
once cells become aneuploid, they also
exhibit a higher degree of basal DNA damage,
and this is not surprising. The link between chromosomal instability and DNA damage
is well established in the literature.
But this also creates to a constant
activation of the DNA damage response that renders these highly aneuploid cells
more resistant to further DNA damage induction.
However, at the same time, this leads to activation of a
MAP kinase signaling, and in particular SRAF, which is important for
the DNA damage response. And this has two potentially relevant
clinical implications. One is that we show that you could use
RAF, MEK, ERK inhibitors that are very important clinically
to selectively kill the highly aneuploid cells.
And the second implication is that by sub-lethal
doses of this inhibition of RAF was
sufficient to resensitize the highly aneuploid cells to DNA
damage-inducing chemotherapies.
And we discovered it with Rp1 cells, but then we showed that it's actually relevant
also across different
data sets of
cancer cell lines and clinical
data from patients. Now, the second
discovery that we made using this new system has to do with dosage
compensation. So the idea is quite simple.
When cells have a aneuploidy and specific when they have extra
chromosomes, then they need to compensate,
especially
for proteins that participate in complexes that are encoded from
different chromosomes.
And they do it both at the mRNA and at the protein level.
So what we found was that at the mRNA level, when you have extra chromosomes, you
have more transcription, but then there's also more RNA
degradation that is mediated both by
NMD and the microRNA pathways. However, there's
still too much RNA, and therefore,
there's also an attempt of the
cell to down-regulate translation and to activate
proteasome inhibition. Now, all of these create
vulnerabilities in these cells, because if you interfere with RNA degradation or
with protein degradation, then the highly aneuploid cells
are particularly sensitive to that.
And this is in particular important for proteasome inhibitors because proteasome
inhibitors are used in the clinic for multiple myeloma.
They failed
in clinical trials for many solid tumors.
When we took
data from clinical trials,
with proteasome
inhibitors in multiple solid tumors, and we stratified the
patients retroactively based on their degree of aneuploidy, we actually
found that the highly aneuploid cells are more sensitive to these
drugs. So now we hope to try to take it to more
translational directions as well and see if it holds true in
specific, interesting clinical contexts.
Now, with that, I want to switch gear to discussing the synthetic lethalities
of specific aneuploidies.
And the first type of vulnerabilities I want to discuss
is oncogene addiction and haploinsufficiency.
Because now we get into the specific genes that reside on the
altered chromosomes and not a general consequence of imbalance
or of a high level of
aneuploidy. So, also in this, we can think about
synthetic lethalities here. We can think both about targeting the drivers and
targeting the passengers. In this regard, the aneuploidy
creates opportunities that don't really exist with specific
oncogenes and tumor suppressor genes because we don't necessarily
have to go after the target. There might be genes that reside
next to it, for example, that are co-gained or co-lost
and might be our target. So I want to tell you a few
vignettes related to this direction.
Let's start with the idea of targeting an oncogenic addiction.
So chromosome arm 17p is one of the most common aneuploidies in
general in cancer, but also in particular in breast cancer.
This is true across molecular subtypes.
And
P53 resides on chromosome 17p. It's a major driver of its
loss. We recently showed that even
one
monoallelic loss of P53 in the form of
chromosome 17p monosomy is sufficient to
down-regulate partly the P53 pathway.
And in a study that we published
last year that aimed to identify
potential drivers of recurrent aneuploidies, not surprisingly,
P53 came up as kind of the poster boy of this.
It seems like a bona fide driver of loss of 17p across many
cancer types.
Now,
in collaboration with the Sachi Fainaru lab, we
found that aneuploidy-driven chromosome 17p
loss
can derive breast cancer brain metastasis specifically, and
it does so by altering fatty acid synthesis.
So the idea is that fatty acid synthesis is particularly required
in the brain environment, and the inactivation of
P53 upregulates SCD1, which enables
the cells to synthesize their own monounsaturated fatty
acids. And there's a lot of mechanism that
we discovered in this paper. But for the sake of today's talk, I want to focus on
the fact that this creates an oncogenic addictionBecause
these P53 inactivated
brain metastasizing cancer cells become
dependent on the activation of SCD1.
And there are several SCD1 inhibitors. Some of them are in clinical trials.
And we showed in vitro, ex vivo, and in vivo that
these P53 altered
tumors and loss of 17p altered tumors are actually
preferentially sensitive and very much sensitive
to the inhibition of SCD1. And this is another thing that we're now
trying to translate and see whether SCD1 inhibition could be
a viable therapeutic against
tumors with P53 inactivation, and in particular, in the context of brain
metastasis.
So this was
published just two months ago with a very nice commentary written
by Sam Baccom. And if anyone is interested, I
encourage you to read the full story.
Now, moving on to other types of these synthetic lethalities, I want to
discuss hemizygous dependency. So here we're still
staying with loss of chromosome 17p, but
very close to chromosome 17p, there is the Aurora B
kinase. And we found that Aurora B kinase
expression, both at the mRNA and protein levels, is
downregulated when this chromosome arm is lost.
We see it in cell lines, we see it in tumors.
In fact, it's the number one gene that is being
preferentially downregulated when this chromosome arm is lost.
And interestingly, unlike in many other oncogenic
cases, in this case, when you have less Aurora kinase B expression,
you become more sensitive, not more resistant, to the further
inhibition of the kinase. And therefore, cells that have
lost chromosome arm 17p are also more sensitive
to alvespib than to other Aurora kinase B inhibitors.
So again, I'm kind of just showing the final
conclusions. The story is already on BioRxiv, currently in revision.
But what we found is that
Aurora kinase B can be a unique vulnerability of cancer with
loss of 17p. We show now that it's not only in breast cancer, we
see it actually across many tumor types.
And what I think makes it particularly interesting is the fact that
P53 is actually a
regulator of Aurora kinase B. And when P53 is mutated,
Aurora kinase B expression actually goes up.
So P53 status has been suggested as a marker for
resistance to Aurora kinase B inhibitors.
What we discover is that it depends how P53 is altered.
If it's altered by a mutation, then we see the same thing.
But if it's altered by aneuploidy, we actually see the opposite.
And we think that when you have both of them, because this is a very common
way to biallelically inactivate P53, then you actually resensitize
the P53 mutant cells to Aurora kinase B inhibition.
So we think that, again, can also be important because, as you know,
Aurora kinase B inhibitors have been debated and have
largely failed
in trials. And I think that, again, it goes down to the question of stratifying
the patients, finding the right biomarkers, and the aneuploidy and chromosomal
instability could be particularly important in this
context.
Now, in the last
story I want to share with you, it has to do with
passenger dependency. And here we're
focusing on gains. So this is a study that
was in collaboration with Flores Fougeray and Ramin
Dekhoukhim,
with Michael Schubert and Veronica Rendo, who led it when they were
postdocs. And the idea there was
that we wanted to look for genes that despite residing in
commonly gained regions, so common aneuploidies that are
gained, they are not overexpressed, suggesting that there might be
selection against their overexpression and they might be toxic.
And we combined this. Basically,
we defined two layers here. One is this compensation, so
there's DNA copy number gain, but there's no overexpression.
And the other is that we took advantage of
ORF screens, open reading frame screens, to look for genes that when you
strongly overexpress them, they are indeed toxic for the cells.
And we termed them ARGOS genes, amplification-related gain of
sensitivity. And I just want to share one example
for that. When you do this and you try to
overlap
these different analyses, we found that a gene called RBM14 that
resides right next to cyclin D is
actually
one such gene. So you can see here that it is not
overexpressed, despite the fact that it's commonly gained, and it's commonly gained
because it resides next to a common oncogene.
It's very toxic for cells when you overexpress it.
We also validated it, and when we overexpressed it, we saw a lot of cell death.
We partly characterized the mechanism that has to do with DNA
damage repair, and particularly with non-homologous end joining.
And we showed that this is actually also relevant in a clinical context, because
if
this gene is actually included in
the amplified region and is overexpressed, then there's
indeed a worse prognosis versus
the other option, which is that only CCND1 will be amplified
and RBM14 would not be.Okay.
Lastly, I just want to say that I focused on aneuploidy, but in the
lab, we also look at other consequences of chromosomal instability like whole
genome doubling, chromothripsis, and many other labs
also do it. So this is from a recent study by Paul
Michel and Howard
Chang that
just got published. And found that in ecDNA,
PVT1 is often
fused to a strong oncogene, cMYC, as well as
other oncogenes. And this can actually create different types of
therapeutic vulnerabilities. So just two days ago,
there was a commentary piece that we wrote that was published, and we think
that you can think, for example, fusion junction neoantigens or different
specific molecular mechanism that is described in this paper that might
be relevant specifically for cells with extra chromosomal DNA.
So to summarize, CIN can be targeted therapeutically in at least three
ways. One is that we might be able to manipulate CIN levels below
minimum or above maximum thresholds.
Second way is to exacerbate cellular stresses that are induced by chromosomal
instability and/or its consequences, or by
inhibiting a stress coping mechanism.
And a lot of the work that is currently going on in my lab deals with this.
And third, we can target common CIN-induced genetic alterations, which are the
specific aneuploidies. We generated the
models and datasets to identify such synthetic lethalities.
We have now aneuploidy scores for all the DepMap, about 2,000
human cancer cell lines. We have novel isogenic models,
and there's more to come soon. And we revealed novel dependencies, both of
highly aneuploid cells and of specific aneuploidies, and
I mentioned and discussed most of them
in my talk. With that, I want to thank the people
in my lab, especially those who led the study that I showed today,
our multiple collaborators, the funding mechanism.
And I just want to mention that in November in Berlin, there will be the
first EACR meeting that focuses on chromosomal instability
and its manifestations. And I want to welcome all of you who are interested in
this field to
register and to submit abstract. Registration is already open. Thank you.
Great talk. Any questions? We have about four minutes for questions.
Please go to the microphone.
Yeah.
Yeah, great talk.
Question regarding your statement about 17p loss
being dependent on SD1 amplification. Is there a gain?
No. There's a regulation. P53
transcriptionally regulates SCD1, and
also regulates a partner of SCD1 that
in turn regulates SCD1. There's no genetic amplification of
SCD1. It's just that the loss of P53 leads to
hypertranscription and therefore hyperexpression of SCD1, which
enables the cells to synthesize
monounsaturated fatty acids. And this is exacerbated
and particularly important in the brain microenvironment.
We also show that this is because the astrocytes secrete the substrates for
this enzymatic reaction. So the full mechanism is in the paper if you're
interested in it.
Great talk. Second question.
Hi, Uri. Shai Israeli from Schneider Children.
I didn't know about the association between RAS and aneuploidy.
And it's interesting because in the hyperdiploid
ALL, which is the most common acute lymphoblastic leukemia, the most common
leukemia in children, RAS mutations are part of this
leukemia. So why is RAS is activated in
aneuploidy?
So
what we found was that it seems like SIRAF is the culprit, because SIRAF has
been actually reported to be important
in different contexts for the response to DNA damage and chronic
DNA damage. We also validated it in our isogenic system that the
aneuploid cells actually, they
express SIRAF more and they depend on SIRAF more.
But once SIRAF is activated, the entire cascade
of kind of signaling, the RAF MEK ERK cascade, gets activated as
well.
It's interesting because pan-RAF inhibitors, that's new.
Pan-RAF inhibitors are now developed for neuro-oncology, so
maybe it's
useful for generally for aneuploidy.
Yeah. No, I agree. I think we have several ideas of how to try to look into
translational implications of this finding. Yeah.
Great. And one last question.
Hi. Thank you for the talk. So would targeting chromosomal
instability help us avoid targeting healthy cells in the future?
Yeah. I feel I think that's-- I didn't mention it, but that's one of the key
ideas here, right? Because almost 90% of the solid
tumors, about three-quarters of the malignancies are aneuploid.
Also, the fraction of tumor cells that have ecDNA, that have
chromothripsis, that have whole genome doubling, if you kind of take all these
CIN-related consequences combined, these
are highly, highly prevalent across different types of
tumors. But normal cells nearly don't have it at all.
Now, there are more reports that in some aging tissues, aneuploidy begins to
occur. But by and large, there's a potential very large
therapeutic window here because the normal cells are diploid and
they
cannot tolerate these types of chromosomal catastrophes, whereas the cancer
cells do. So this is kind of the idea behind
targeting it clinically.
Great. Thank you very much, Uri.
And now onto the second talk by Professor Ashley
Loughney. And she will talk to us about cell extrinsic
consequences and immune consequences of chromosomal instability.
And she is at Weill Cornell Medicine.
Thank you. And thanks to the organizers and thanks, Uri, for an amazing
introduction. These are my disclosures.
And so as Uri, I think, alluded to really importantly, there's a difference
between the consequences of SIN and the ongoing cellular process of SIN.
And I love to see that this understanding of an ongoing process is
now finally really coming together with cancer biology very deeply.
If we think about this as a process,
lagging chromosomes, one of the immediate consequence
of them is that they end up frequently in these very fragile rupture-prone
micronuclei. And when those micronuclei rupture, they
expose DNA to the cytosol
and activate the cGAS-STING innate immune signaling pathway.
And what I will tell you today is about how this pathway downstream
signaling is rewired in the context of chronic
activation. And so we'll skip through this slide because
Uri did a great introduction. When we made that discovery, what was shocking was
SIN drives metastasis. We saw that it depended on STING,
this innate immune pathway that was thought to trigger anti-tumor immunity.
And not only did it depend on STING,
when you knock it out, you suppress metastasis.
When you add back STING in a dose-dependent manner, you saw a dose-dependent
increase in metastasis. But it actually depended on interactions with the immune
system. So if we repeated these experiments in severely immune-compromised mice,
that SIN and STING-dependent pro-metastatic effect went away.
And so the question was: How was this happening?
And so at the time, obviously, single-cell has really revolutionized our
ability to understand the tumor microenvironment and how it's changing.
We, at the time, developed a new method called contact tracing, which the real
innovation of this approach is that it exploits intrinsic
variability captured by your single-cell experiments in both receptor
expression on the target cell that would be responding to the stimulus and
ligand availability in the microenvironment.
And so by exploiting these true
biologically meaningful sources of variation in single-cell data, we
can actually infer from the data that you collect in a native in
vivo microenvironment, how is a cell responding to a given stimulus?
And so this is an example of how the predicted response of a macrophage
to CCL2 activation. I've highlighted known up and down-regulated
target genes that have been independently validated.
You can access the source code to the approach here.
And so using this approach, it allowed us to classify and
prioritize interactions in a meaningful way that allowed us to say, okay, what
effects of chromosomal instability, which we can dial up or dial down rates
of missegregation or STING, what interactions were
leading to an altered immune microenvironment measurably in
the single-cell data? And so the summary of this finding was
that we actually depended on the STING-dependent ER stress response.
So it turns out,
through chronic activation of this pathway, STING kind of dampens
its interferon responses significantly and really
rewires downstream signaling towards this unfolded protein response to ER stress.
And in fact, if you take chromosomally unstable cancer models and you knock out any
one of the three arms that mediate an unfolded protein response
to ER stress, it
significantly suppresses metastasis, again, in a manner dependent on the
immune system. Now, this experiment obviously did not test was it truly
STING-dependent ER stress. We've since this paper validated that as
well. We knock out STING, we suppress metastasis.
Add back full-length STING, you restore that metastatic potential.
Add back a variant of STING deficient and mounting an ER stress response,
the rescue no longer works.
And so how does this occur? Sam's going to talk about chronicity of STING
activation, I know, also in his talk, but I think it's a really important concept.
So even in diploid cells, these are human iMR90 fibroblasts.
When you activate that STING signaling pathway once, transient activation, you
get a robust 200-fold interferon response here.
But when you chronically activate that pathway, chromosomally unstable cells
missegregate every two to five cell divisions.
They're frequently exposing DNA to the cytosol.
So we simulate that here with chronic activation.
So with five daily treatments of CGAMP, you see that this red line, that
interferon response goes away. There's a tachyphylaxis or
desensitization of the interferon response.
And conversely, we see a lot of transcripts associated with
responding to ER stress are upregulated.
And so I always love to give the analogy of a car alarm.
You hear it once, you look, you sound the alarm.
If that alarm keeps beeping and beeping and beeping, you're going to tune that out.
And the cells actually get stressed out.
No cell wants to constitutively produce interferon.
And so I think STING is a beautiful example.
One of an immune regulatory protein that can both stimulate
and suppress the immune response.
So how does one protein give rise to such diverse
functions?One mechanism of
adaptation is obviously through distinct structural compartments.
And so STING is no exception. Actually, its ability to mount an interferon response
is entirely encoded on its C-terminal tail that evolved only in
vertebrates. So STING actually had many primordial roles even back in
bacteria. But they had nothing to do with interferon production.
These were associated with NF-kappa B, autophagy, ER stress.
And so obviously I've talked about how, in the context of chromosomally
unstables where STING is chronically activated, in that case, we really
would want to inhibit STING signaling.
But in tumors that have not adapted to this chronic state, maybe STING
activation would be great for those patients.
So,
the challenge of one protein having many functions is when you want to target that
protein, which function are you targeting?
Can we move towards separation of function drugs, right?
That separate, let's say, target just that immune suppressive ER stress
function of STING while keeping that anti-tumor interferon
intact. That is the goal. And so towards this, we've developed a
technology that we call Stat-seq, that basically marches along a
protein. STING is 379 amino acids, so for each
building block or amino acid of that protein, we systematically mutate that
amino acid to every conceivable counterpart.
So we have 19 possible substitutions at each site.
Each of these mutations is coupled to a DNA barcode that tells us what
position was mutated, and with long-read sequencing, we can actually confirm
what substitution was made specifically at that site.
So we have 100% coverage, at least for the STING protein.
Other proteins can be a little trickier.
Of every possible synthetic single
residue substitution of this protein.
These mutational barcodes we can readily capture with single-cell sequencing, so
obviously we have about 7,000 approximate variants of
STING that we're profiling. There's no way we could do that in series.
So we assay them with single-cell readouts.
And so for example, we could look at our variant
barcoded library of STING before and after cGAMP stimulation and
say, "Okay, how do these variants respond to activation of the STING pathway, and
how is that different from complementation with full-length STING?" Again,
we've engineered the whole system so we can put in all our favorite controls.
Complementation with full-length STING, complementation with variants
expressing stop codons that don't produce protein.
And that allows us to basically, by comparing gene expression in the variant
versus complementation with full-length STING, which I'll call Ref,
map predominantly through loss of function, the function of every part
of the protein. And then we can of course map that to 3D structures
and then say, "When are these functions important?" So let's take those barcoded
variant libraries, implant them, let's say in the mammary fat pad.
We often study triple-negative breast cancer.
And then compare barcode enrichment, let's say in spontaneous
metastases to the lung compared to their matched primary tumor.
Or use these variant libraries to look at how drugs interact with their target.
And so in the functional genomics landscape, the real advantage, obviously deep
saturation mutagenesis has been around a very long time.
It's an extremely powerful technology.
Readouts are mostly one-dimensional, right?
And so you're biased towards the measured function, which you already probably know
a lot about because you chose that measured function, right?
There are also emerging base and primary editing technologies
that are becoming more efficient. But they still have a scalability issue.
There's no way you're using base or prime editing for every single possible
mutation of a protein. But from an endogenous gene
regulatory framework and for patient-observed mutations, they're
great strategies.
Stat-seq allows us to look at every possible variant and measure genome-wide
responses with no kind of bias towards the measured function.
Of course, the limitation is it's a cDNA overexpression system.
So we are looking at, we know the protein is expressed.
So actually the variants that we capture that have phenotypic
consequences typically are associated with sites of post-translational
modifications or that disrupt key binding partners or trafficking.
And so this is an example of how we can actually map which parts of STING are
responsible, let's say, for protein stability.
And so basically for these variant libraries, we can put them kind of
like through the Olympics, right?
I think if they have to jump over different hurdles.
So, as long as you have a good antibody that you can sort your library on,
you can sort for that. So we activate, this is actually not with cGAMP
activation. This is endogenous levels of STING.
We can see we have a nice, when you complement with Ref, we can separate that
from variants we know do not express protein.
We can apply these gates to the whole library, right?
We want to make sure we're making real protein.
And we see most of the variants express full,
almost all express the protein.
And then we've actually developed machine learning models now that say, "Okay, what
is the impact of a mutation, the position
substitution, any substitution at that site, mutation alone, or some
interaction effect between the position and mutation on the measured
fitness?" Which in this case is protein stability.
And so here that is mapped for, again, the 379 positions of
STING, every possible substitution.
And we've mapped the results of this here onto the 3D structure of STING.
And what's really interesting is you see most variants express
strongly STING protein, but there are some regions in the
cGAMP binding domain that reduce STING protein levels.
And this, I didn't
show you the data that was in the paper I described previously, but chronic
activation of STING leads to lower STING levels, right?
Whenever STING activates interferon, it wants to limit.
There's autophagy-dependent degradation of STING.
And so similarly, when we actually plot these scores and subclone out
individual variants, we see that we actually, it's like doing, you could do
basically 7,000 kind of individual western blots with this, right?
The score tracks really well with the protein levels captured at the
western level. And we see a lot of these constitutively activating mutations of
STING indeed show reduced protein.
But it's still there and it's functional.And so how do we
map the function? We want to go from generate sequence function relationships in
the cellular context and ultimately in growing tumors, because context matters.
Where you measure these genomic perturbations influences the functions
that you're going to capture. And so we took two triple negative models of breast
cancer, U771 and 4T1, and we've engineered the
complete bar-coded STING mutagenesis libraries in these.
And first, we just wanted to ensure that STING was activated.
So this is in vitro before and after STING activation with cGAMP.
And so I'm highlighting here loss of function domains that were identified this.
So we basically compare each variant to full-length STING and say, "Okay, which are
behaving differently? Which functions are lost?"
And so, for example, here I'm highlighting the selective interferon loss of
function domain. So you can see, of course, canonical regions in the
cGAMP binding domain, key serine residues in the C-terminal tail
that mediate TBK1 phosphorylation are detected.
We also see that oligomerization domain
can lead to selective loss of STING function.
To validate this, we've engineered cells that express
GFP downstream of an interferon
response element. And we've actually sorted the library
also based on this. And so here,
this is showing the rank. So you can see, for example, the stop variant
exhibits the strongest loss of function.
This is the same data now captured by flow, and I've highlighted in
blue what we called from single cells an interferon loss of
function. Similarly, we've actually mapped some ER stress loss of
function domains and validated these through ATF3 protein expression,
which in our hands was our strongest
protein-based reporter of STING-dependent
ER stress that we could use for flow.
And really intriguingly, Nir Hacohen's lab a couple of years ago actually
showed that STING can act as a proton pump in
this region here. And so this may be contributing to that ER stress
loss.
Next, we wanted to say, when are these functions important?
And so here I'm showing you the metastatic fitness. So we took 30 mice.
We compared the barcode enrichment in matched tumors from each spontaneous
lung met to its matched primary tumor across every position of
STING with every possible substitution.
Red means enriched in metastasis. Blue means depleted.
If there's a star on the box, sorry, I know it's a lot of data, that
basically means the effect is reproducible significantly across the 30
mice. Here, I've collapsed those findings per position.
So variants here that are amplified or highlighted
mean any substitution at those sites
increases metastatic fitness. And in fact, the
substitution at this lysine 337 has been, even though STING is
not typically mutated in cancer, there has been a patient with a mutation
detected specifically at this site.
We've also, when we consider how we interpret these ligand effects, or
sorry, these variant effects, we also consider sequence homology
across species. Are these frequently altered regions? Are they highly conserved?
And are there mutations observed in human cancer?
And so here I'm highlighting the key top pro and
anti-metastatic variants of STING that we've identified.
It's really important to note if you compare fitness in primary tumors versus
metastases, these are not correlated.
STING has strong fitness pressure in the metastatic setting,
not so much in the primary tumor.
We've individually validated both anti and
pro-metastatic variants because, of course, STING, whether it's
activating or inhibiting the immune system, acts through
interactions with the microenvironment. So we thought there could be cheaters.
So maybe one of the variants could be secreting a factor.
And so we've shown for the key variants that we followed up on that, no, indeed,
they individually validate even our loss of function. They don't lose STING.
They have very high expression. And also for gain of function, we see
this substitution at position lysine 337 and this proline at
13a we've been following up on indeed
reduce survival in these mice. They metastasize faster.
It's not explained by loss of STING.
And we have confirmed that actually we observe mutations at every
site. It's not a sampling issue.
And so
what is underlying this? We think that the STING activation life cycle
is being disrupted in metastasis.
So typically, when cGAS senses cytosolic DNA, it produces
cGAMP, which binds to STING sitting as this obligate homodimer in the ER.
And what's really interesting about control of STING is that its activity is
coupled to its location in the cell.
So as soon as it's activated, it translocates ER to the Golgi
where higher order oligomers must form.
And through those higher order oligomers, that's when you get phospho-TBK1,
eventually phospho-IRF3, which should lead to these
IRF3 dependent
interferon functions as well as NF-kappa
B signaling. And so what we think is happening in our models is that
we see it's very strong in the metastatic variants
phosphorylation of TBK1. That is retained.
So this initial step is happening, but there seems to be a defect in
phosphorylation of STING, which typically occurs after
phospho-TBK1 and a reduction in
phospho-IRF3. So there seems to be a defect here.
We're still trying to tease apart whether that's driven by a defect in
oligomerization, which the loss of function controlled data would suggest,
or trafficking, which we're exploring STING binding partners with mass spec
to get at that more specifically. And so ultimately
our goal is to basically use deep mutagenesis as a tool, not
just to look at patient observed variants, but to use this as a tool
for context-aware modeling. And the context that we care about, of course, is
chromosomal instability. And we're increasingly integrating
proteomic readouts into this becauseRealizing how important
these are.
And so the goal here is, of course, moving towards structure-function
relationships. And even with the revolution in AI, I think it's
very clear that if you want to predict function beyond calling something benign or
pathogenic, we need better training data in real cells, like in a
context that matters. And so we hope that this platform will provide that.
And of course, we're also thinking about precision drug development.
So I'm just going to give one slide of kind of a
flash about that precision delivery.
So the idea we had was we have every possible synthetic variant of our protein of
interest. We know drugs act through on and off-target drug mechanisms.
So the idea was, hey, if there's a off-target drug effect, it should affect all
variants uniformly. But if there's an on-target effect and you mutate a site
at or near where the drug binds, that drug effect should go away.
And so we actually took--
This is just looking at distance and gene expression space,
all highly variable genes of our barcoded variant library before and after
drug addition. This is of one of the first STING agonists to be developed.
And clinically,
as expected, our control with the stop codons, no STING protein,
exhibits the least response to the drug.
Complement with full-length STING, you get a robust response to the drug.
Why did this drug, DMXAA, fail in clinical trials?
There's actually a single amino acid difference between mouse and human STING,
even though they're structurally so similar, and we know very well how
cGAMP binds, and these drugs are cGAMP analogs.
That single amino acid substitution was at the drug binding
site. Where was that drug binding site? Here at position 229.
So we could have predicted that before clinical trials, right?
And what was really interesting-- So after this resistance
mutation was described in humans, a year later, another
study came out that basically said, well, actually, if patients have a
mutation of the serine position 161, then they still will
respond to this drug that otherwise only works in mice.
And we also were able to predict these hypersensitizing mutations.
Obviously, this STING agonist is no longer in clinical development, but many
activators and inhibitors are in early stage studies,
so we're readily applying to this.
And so with that, I'll conclude just by introducing the key players in this.
So obviously, a lot of this work, especially the ER stress story, was a
collaboration with Sam Bakum, who you'll hear next, and his lab.
The Satseq platform was developed by a very talented post-doc, Matt Dayel, in the
lab and is being applied to STING signaling in vivo by
Amelia Onstad, a very talented grad student who's also been
integrating a lot of proteomic readouts.
Melissa and Austin have applied and developed actually a lot of the computational
tools to predict cis-independent effects on the microenvironment.
And Amitava Banerjee is developing a lot of the AI-based tools to
predict the impact of a variant on function.
And so with that, I will gladly take questions and of course,
acknowledge the funding and great team
I'm privileged to work with. So thank you for your attention.
Great. If you have any questions, please proceed to the microphone.
Go ahead.
All right. I'm interested to hear your thoughts on
why STING isn't mutated more in cancer.
As you showed, it has a lot of function.
So I think if it was that simple, if we thought of STING and
interferon as synonymous, and that was its only function, it would have been
mutated. It has other essential roles, right?
In ER stress, autophagy. And those functions matter at
different stages of disease progression.
And so I think it's-- What was it? The Mueller's Red.
There's too much selection coming from both
ways. So there is no need for selection.
And I think I say pleiotropy like it's this new thing, one
protein, many functions. That's how all the proteins in our body work.
And what matters is who, even in the cellular context, what binding
partners are available? What is the-- So it's not
simply to be explained by just loss through
mutagenesis.
Thanks.
All right. Second question.
Yeah. Great talk. I was just interested, might be I missed,
because the STING phosphorylated on S366,
R358. So did you try those double mutation
and their effect?
So we did not do double mutations, but that's a good point.
Actually, there's multiple serine sites on the C-terminal tail, and
for phospho-IRF3, you need to have two phosphorylated.
Phospho-TBK1 doesn't necessarily--
I think there's a difference between TBK1 functions of STING that are
independent of IRF3.
But we haven't done double mutants together.
Yeah. Why? Because I have interest because the STING also
have C-terminal deleted isoform.
Yes.
Right.
We did spike that in. So basically any of the major
described known loss of function mutations,
RRDD, RRAA, Delta CTT, we engineered those,
barcoded them, and spiked them in as good positive controls to make sure that when
we predict loss of function with this new technology, that it's in line with
what is known in the field.
Thanks.
Yeah, thanks for this.
Another question in the middle.
You showed
mutation
of STING in relation to lung cancer.
But do you know if
any of these mutation are related to organ tropism or any
other mutation leads to a different site of metastasis?
So in this case, this was actually a triple negative model of breast cancer that
metastasized to the lung. We did not do tropism studies in this
work.
But you could, right? I think that's a great question.
I think it's just a matter ofBandwidth.
And
the first pilot of this, we know that these mice readily
and early on spontaneously metastasize to the lung.
So it was just a bit easier to develop the technology
as a start. Yeah.
Okay. Go ahead. Thanks.
I have a question about this technology.
I think it's very powerful to study
or discover new function of STING.
Mm-hmm.
And recently people found that STING has a proton channel
function that mediates autophagy and-
Mm-hmm
... other
interferon independent functions.
Can you use this technology to discover how
specific STING residues that mediates proton channel downstream
autophagy?
Yeah. What's really interesting, if you look at the ER stress called loss of
functions, there was
a cluster near where that proton channel function was
described.
So I definitely think so. I think for ER stress, we need good
other protein readouts that we can readily, easily sort by flow.
And some of that has been challenging to do in vitro.
If you have markers of ER stress that you think would be useful to sort these
barcode, we could
add that to further those studies.
Thank you.
So thanks for the suggestion.
One last question.
Thank you very much. Really beautiful work.
Got a question about your detection of protein.
Were your variants tagged in any way?
And just in terms of the detection, and was there any difference
in or any change in localization of the protein?
Yes. So for the protein assays where we have good antibodies, so for
STING, ATF3, we do not tag the
proteins.
We have tagged to do mass spec, our more pro-metastatic
variants, the proline at the N-terminus, the P13 and
K337. We see a very striking trafficking phenotype
for the V5 tagged protein. We did not see
that as striking without the V5 tag, which obviously we know
that proline substitution is near the N-terminal
tag. We do know if you tag STING at the C-terminal, its function is
altered as well. So we've mostly used untagged versions,
but to
query mass spec binding partners, but we did add the V5
tag. I'm still trying to tease apart-- I think that tag also may
just
amplify in a subtle effect that's there.
So we're still working on the trafficking
phenotype. I think there is some signal.
It's just not ready for prime time yet.
Thank you. And just, you had a Western blot, and maybe it's my
misunderstanding of it, but-
Okay
... these are single residue changes, but some of them had dramatic
shifts in molecular weight.
Oh.
Let's talk after. For a STING itself?
There shouldn't be. Yeah.
Just so I make sure I'm... Thank you.
Great. Thank you very much. All right.
Okay, great. So the last talk of the session.
I have the pleasure to tell you a little bit about our efforts to
translate some of our work on chromosomal instability into the clinic,
and really talking about two parts.
One is the cell intrinsic approach, and the cell extrinsic approach.
And before I do this, these are my disclosures.
I'm a co-founder and chief scientific officer of Velastra
Therapeutics. And the aim here is to take some of these mechanistic
insights towards the clinic, and Velastra is developing one of the
KIF18A inhibitors that are out there.
So you heard from Uri today about the cell
intrinsic mechanisms of chromosomal instability and aneuploidy and
approaches to targeting them. And one really
interesting target that came out from Uri's lab as well as others,
Neil Ganem and Jason Stumpf, is KIF18A, and it's
thought to be a synthetic lethal target
in the context of abnormal chromosome contents.
I think Uri had mentioned in his paper, I think there was an
emphasis on aneuploidy. In Neil Ganem's paper, there was an
emphasis on whole genome doubling.
And in Jason Stumpf's paper, there was an emphasis on overall
chromosomal instability. So I will tell you a little
bit about updated results of what we think is the mechanism of
response for KIF18A inhibitors and how we can use that to develop a potential
biomarker.
The first part of the talk, I'm going to talk about STING again,
and a very simple approach to try and propose
to resensitize tumors to STING agonists that
are currently being tested in clinical trials.
So STING agonists are obviously a very interesting area in cancer
therapeutics, and the purpose of developing activators of
STING is, and the intention is, to induce type one
interferon response, because that would then initiate the adaptive immune
response and potentiate antitumor immunity.
However, there's obviously multiple STING agonists currently in
development. This is one of the first ones that were reported.
It became clear that their efficacy was not what we were hoping for.
We, I mean, as a field, especially when we look at the
preclinical models where we see strong efficacy.
And in fact, in this very initial study,
most of the tumors did not exhibit a response to STING agonists, but
one patient that had a PR was a Merkel cell carcinoma, which is
known to have a large proportion of tumors that are not chromosomally unstable.
So based on the mechanistic work that you heard from the second talk
by Ashley, it was clear that in chromosomally
unstable tumors, there is exposure of double-stranded DNA to the
cytoplasm.And this exposure is actually ongoing and continuous.
And so probably the hypothesis is in these tumors, which is
chromosomal instability is actually a very widely prevalent phenotype in advanced
patients, especially in phase one trial patients.
In these tumors, the
tumor has been bathing in cGAMP, which is the endogenous STING agonist,
for a very long time and has developed adaptive resistance mechanisms
to further activation of the pathway.
And this is just an example of what the micronuclei look like.
These micronuclei rupture, exposing double-stranded DNA to the
cytoplasm.
Prior to this, there has been kind of an assumption that STING and
cGAS are actually lost in cancer, and I think
after staining close to 1,000 tumor samples, I can probably
confidently say that is not necessarily something that we see.
But we do see suppression of type I interferon.
And I think the confusion arose from using STING as synonymous
to interferon. However, what we're seeing is STING and cGAS are expressed,
they're chronically expressed, and there is no type I interferon.
This is an example of a high-grade serous ovarian cancer
sample zoomed in on a single primary
nucleus with two micronuclei. And in one of the
micronuclei that is ruptured, you can see very strong cGAS staining.
And in fact, when you zoom out and actually look kind of a
broad picture at what high-grade serous ovarian tumors look like,
this is a platinum refractory resistant case.
And in this image here, there is more
cGAS positive, AKA ruptured micronuclei than
primary nuclei. I think this really tells us two things.
One is chromosomal instability is not kind of a one-shot deal or a one event,
and that's the end of the story. This is an ongoing process.
Every time cells divide, they make errors, these micronuclei show up.
But then that cGAS activation is actually a chronic
process also happening in these chromosomally unstable tumors.
And so the hypothesis was very simple.
If cGAS is activated naturally from chromosomal instability, cGAMP is
being made,
then the tumor's not going to respond to just additional STING
activation or STING agonist. And
to further build on this, we found that these
tumors have STING, and if you knock out STING, you do
not... Oh, sorry, if you activate STING with cGAMP, endogenous cGAMP, you don't
get significant increase in type I interferon, but these cells can
still make interferon. If you transfect these cells with poly IC, which is an
activator of the double-stranded RNA sensing pathway, you get thousands of folds
induction of type I interferon. You've seen this data already
in the second talk, but just briefly to kind of summarize it, because it's really
fundamental to the rest of this story.
If we treat cells that don't have cGAS activation at
baseline with cGAMP, you get this very strong interferon
response. If you treat them the second day, you get 80% of the
response. By day three, 50%. By day four, 20%, and by
day five, it's a flat line. You don't get interferon response anymore.
And this is STING specific because if we actually treat these cells with poly IC,
you get a very good response. So something is happening within
five days of seeing cGAMP. STING is very quickly
dampening type I interferon.
The flip is ER stress, as you've seen, so I'm not going to spend a lot
of time. So basically after chronic activation, interferon goes
down, ER stress goes up, and ER stress in this case is immune suppressive.
What we also saw was really interesting,
and this was by chance. The postdoc in the lab who was doing this just wanted to
be efficient and knocked out cGAS and STING and stained for both of them at the
same time. And one thing we saw that was really interesting and caught our eye is
people
look at this and say, "STING is lost in cancer." I understand, but every
time you knock out cGAS, STING levels go up.
And we hypothesized that maybe what's happening is that when
cGAS is chronically activated, STING is basically
trafficked from the ER to the ER Golgi intermediate to the lysosome for
degradation. It's a negative feedback loop.
And when cancer has low levels of STING, maybe this is a sign rather
than STING is not active, it's actually chronically active.
And what we're capturing is this intermediate state of
protein production and degradation. It's a steady state.
And when you knock out cGAS, you suppress that chronic activation.
STING levels go up, but it's mostly in the ER, and it's actually inactive,
but it's primed to be activated. And this is also true if we treat cells with
Bafilomycin, wild-type cells that have cGAS and they're
chromosomally unstable. You get a time-dependent increase in STING
levels because you're not degrading it anymore.
But you don't get that phenotype or effect when you knock out cGAS.
It's high to begin with because it's not activated, and there's no further increase
because there's no point. Inhibiting degradation doesn't really impact it because
it's not being trafficked or degraded to begin with.
And one other piece of data that was really interesting
is if you allow the system to rest from chronic
cGAMP activation, so just give the cells seven days
to rest from this kind of chronic activation, you actually restore type I
interferon when you kind of activate it acutely seven days
later. So that gave us this idea, if STING is chronically
activated, it's not producing type I interferon.
Why don't we inhibit cGAS to allow the system to
reset, to build STING levels, to stop this chronic activation
and this tachyphylaxis of desensitization of interferon, and then
hit it really hard with STING agonist?
So it's actually a bit of counterintuitive.
You inhibit the pathway in order to activate it downstream.
And this worked really well in vitro, at least here, and I'll show you some in vivo
results. We've done this in seven
different cancer models. I'm just showing you two.
LKB1
mutant lung cancer model provided to us by
Kwok-Wong at NYU and a 41 model here.
And you see if you add cGAMP to wild-type cells, you don't get an
interferon response. You knock out cGAS-To alleviate the
chronic activation, and you get a rip-roaring interferon response when you add
cGAMP or STING agonist. It doesn't matter what agonist or activator you
use. And this is clearly STING dependent, because if you double
knockout STING and cGAS, that effect is completely gone.
And we see this over and over to varying degrees in multiple tumor models.
So the big question is then what happens with tumor
sensitivity in vivo to STING agonist?
So one thing I have to mention is a lot
of the experiments in vivo were conducted where the STING agonist treatment was
done on literally the day of tumor implantation,
sometime even the day before, to prime the system.
And I would call this more tumor rejection than therapy.
So we allowed the tumors to grow for a week and then
treated them with STING agonists.
And these chromosomally unstable tumor cells have very little response
to STING agonists once this tumor's been established.
However, when you knock out cGAS, you get a significant
sensitization of the-- And this is knocking out cGAS in the tumor
cells. You get significant sensitization to STING agonists and
prolonged survival, and in fact, some of these mice are cured.
And again, we've done this in multiple models. We've knocked out STING in the host.
I'm happy to discuss all of this, but just to show you the highlight.
So we then used a
tool compound.
It's an inhibitor of cGAS. It's RU521.
We did not optimize this inhibitor for the purposes of this experiment, but it was
just a proof of concept. We've taken these lung models or triple negative breast
cancer models and treated them with a STING agonist, MSA-2, and there
was very little response. And then when we pre-treated these tumors
with RU521, which is a cGAS inhibitor, we were able
to see enhanced
response to the STING agonist, suggesting that pre-treatment
of tumors or patients with cGAS inhibitors to
dampen this chronic inflammatory signaling might actually be a
really good idea
for administration of STING agonist that is more successful
because we can dose the STING agonist at the interval you want,
and you don't have this interference happening from constant cGAMP
production in response to chromosomal instability in the tumor.
We've also done this experiment where we knocked out the mouse.
So RU521 is only a mouse cGAS inhibitor, not a human.
So we knocked out the mouse cGAS and reintroduced the human cGAS,
and it no longer works, suggesting that it's really the cancer cell
cGAS inhibition that is really important.
And I'm happy to discuss that further. Oh, sorry.
So we then asked
whether--
There are two states for cGAS/STING in response to chromosomal instability.
One state is the pathway is not active at baseline.
These are usually chromosomally stable tumors.
And in that case, we think STING agonists might actually work because the pathway
is not activated at baseline, so activating it will give a type one interferon
response. Then there is the chronic state.
So the inhibition of cGAS, the idea is you're taking patients or tumors
that exist in this chronically active state back to the acute
state or kind of copying what chromosomally stable tumors
look like because you're breaking the chromosomal instability cGAS/STING
axis, and you're basically trying to disrupt this chronic
inflammation signal. But we then asked whether
cGAS and STING can be used as a biomarker for STING monotherapy.
This is very preliminary, so take it
as a word of caution. This is hypothesis generating.
But we collaborated with Professor Eileen Parks and Professor Kevin Harrington,
and looked at 12 head and neck squamous cell carcinoma patients
who were enrolled in a dose escalation STING agonist study and looked at cGAS
and STING in these tumors. And this is true, actually, we've seen that in breast
tumors as well. When cGAS is up in micronuclei,
STING levels are low in cancer cells.
And they're low because it's being activated and degraded, not because
it's inactive. So it's actually chronic activation. So cGAS high, STING low.
And the other way around, when cGAS is not on micronuclei,
we see very high levels of STING in cancer cells.
The stroma is always highly expressing because the stroma doesn't have micronuclei.
So we basically asked whether the cGAS high, STING low, cGAS low, STING high
in pre-treatment samples could predict response to STING agonists.
Of course, it's very hard to get sufficient samples homogenized in
the same cancer type in these dose escalation studies, so we have
to contend with a small number here.
But in these 12 patients, we did see that the responders tended to
have low levels of cGAS-positive micronuclei and high
levels of STING, and the inverse was also true.
Patients that had high levels of cGAS and low levels of STING did not
respond. So at least this could potentially be developed
further into a
patient selection biomarker.
And obviously the dream is to basically therapeutically intervene
by inhibiting cGAS to allow everybody to basically
respond to these STING agonists or
more patients to respond to it than they currently do.
So this is kind of the summary of the first part of the talk,
where basically this pathway has the potential to
be a strong therapeutic
target or STING in particular. But we need to do it at the right
cadence, at the right time, and the right context, which is the acute activation,
and this gives you the anti-tumor response, high levels of interferon response.
Once it's allowed to chronically activate, as in with
cGAMP production because of chromosomal instability, it gives you
this ER stress response, and it becomes basically
non-responsive to further STING agonism.
It's no surprise if you give a patient PARP inhibitors sub-therapeutically for
five yearsor any drug for that matter,
there's a very high likelihood that five years later, they may not respond to a
therapeutic dose because the tumor figures a way out of it, and this actually just
takes five days.
But we're lucky in that it's reversible.
Okay, so with that part of the talk, I'm going to switch back to the cell
intrinsic
consequences of chromosomal instability, and a theme that you heard earlier
in Uri's talk is KIF18A and KIF18A inhibitors.
So in 2021, KIF18A
became this really interesting target in chromosomal instability
and led to
quite a bit of effort to develop inhibitors to KIF18A.
It's a kinesin protein that walks on microtubules, and it's important in
satisfying the spindle assembly checkpoint.
And when KIF18A is inhibited, normal cells divide fine.
T cells can divide, normal epithelial cells can divide.
So it's actually a cancer selective antimitotic agent.
What was clear, however, in clinical development is that
KIF18A inhibition doesn't work in every
chromosomally unstable tumor. So it was clear that while chromosomal
instability, aneuploidy, and whole genome doubling are
necessary for the synthetic lethal, they're not sufficient.
In other words, there's
a subset of chromosomally unstable tumors that
likely will respond, not every tumor type.
So through a concerted effort to identify a biomarker for
KIF18A response, and actually in addition, a mechanism of response, we
focused on the spindle assembly checkpoint, which as Uri mentioned, is really
the way by which KIF18A makes cells
sensitive to inhibition.
So spindle assembly checkpoint is a complex signaling cascade that
ultimately
is distilled in a protein called MAD2 that goes to the
kinetochores, which are the attachment sites of chromosomes to microtubules.
And it basically is signaling and forces the cells to wait
until all the chromosomes have aligned, and boom, once they've all
aligned, MAD2 falls off and anaphase can happen.
If you knock out KIF18A, cells kind of remain in mitosis for a long
time. MAD2 remains active and cells die because they
can't arrest the mitosis for more than a couple of hours and survive.
So once cells arrest the mitosis for more than a couple of hours, they either die
during mitosis or as soon as they exit.
But not every cell
line would arrest in response to KIF18A inhibition.
So we started looking at regulators of the spindle assembly
checkpoint signaling, and actually zeroed in on RB,
because it turns out from old literature in 2003, and
I'm sorry
I should have had the citation here, Hernandez et al in Nature
2003. It turns out that E2F is actually a
key regulator of MAD2, and E2F
directly leads to the transcription of MAD2.
So
if RB is activated, E2F is restrained, and
MAD2 levels are probably within the normal range.
However, when RB is lost,
E2F goes up, activity goes up, and you make a lot of
MAD2, and this is probably the substrate that
KIF18A inhibitors need in order to arrest the cells
and impart their therapeutic effect.
And in addition, E2F is also a
transcription factor for CDKN2A or p16.
So in one way, MAD2 levels are up. This is what
you need for KIF18A inhibition. But also you're getting
p16, which is a protein that's widely used in the clinic in head and neck
cancers and cervical cancers to identify HPV associated
tumors. And why is it used there? Because HPV basically
knocks out RB through E6 and E7, and so
p16 is a marker for RB pathway inactivation.
And the reason it's a marker for RB pathway inactivation is because E2F is trying
to reactivate RB through p16, but if RB is genomically lost
or if it's hyperphosphorylated from cyclin E and CDK2,
you get very little--
p16 alone cannot restore RB function,
basically. But it's a really good biomarker.
So we tested this hypothesis pre-clinically in three different
cell line panels using different KIF18A inhibitors.
This study was not done with the purpose of looking for RB.
This was a breadth of efficacy study with various inhibitors
in a large panel of close to 1,000 cell lines.
And basically what we find is the cells that we know have
alterations in the RB pathway tend to be more sensitive in each of
these than the ones that don't have alterations in the RB pathway.
And this was recently deposited in a preprint as well.
And when we look at RB1 gene alteration, you see
a really striking effect, and you see this across histologies,
across different tumor derived cell lines.
So it's not just in one tumor context.
If you look at matched histology matched data,
this is the percentile sensitivity of
lung-- just a way to interpret this, lung cancer cells treated with
AM-182, which is a KIF18A inhibitor, if they are RB
wild type or RB intact, and this is the percentile
sensitivity if they are RB disrupted.
And this is multiple cell lines in each.
This is the median sensitivity, the median percentile.
It's clear that in most cases, you're seeing a significant
increase in sensitivity in cells even matched to histology in
cells that have RB pathway inactivation.
And if you look at the RB1 gene directly, this becomes actually rather
striking.So this was really interesting because
as you know there's a lot of effort to develop KIF15A inhibitors in
human, in chromosomally unstable tumors.
And I think the early efforts appropriately so focused on high-grade serous
ovarian cancer. If you recall, I showed you a picture
of a high-grade serous ovarian cancer sample with more micronuclei than
primary nuclei. So it's undoubtedly a very chromosomally unstable disease.
But even then,
the responses were not compelling.
When patients responded, there was some real responses,
durable responses, but not everybody benefited from the therapy.
So we then decided to do a retrospective analysis
of the two, as far as we know,
two
most advanced, if you will, KIF15A inhibitors,
VLS-1488 and savolnisib.
And this is a dose escalation, dose optimization
studies.
And we stained for p16 as a marker of
RB loss. And it doesn't matter what the mechanism of loss is,
p16 is usually up
in these samples and pre-treatment samples.
And this could be archival samples or right before they go on
therapy. And the reason we were okay with archival is
because loss of RB is usually thought of to be a rather early
event or a truncal alteration. So once a tumor is
p16 high
it typically remains so or the chances of changes is not very common
unless with some contexts like CDK4/6 inhibitor resistance after
prolonged treatment. And what we found is strong positivity for
p16 was found in about
40% or so of these tumor samples,
and quite consistent between the two drugs, the two cohorts.
And that was really important that we did the study in two separate
drugs and in two separate
studies. The two drugs have the same mechanism of action because it can tell
us if what we're seeing is a drug-specific effect or
finding versus a true kind of mechanistic on-target
phenotype or phenomena. And the results were really quite exciting.
p16 positivity picked up every single
partial response except one.
So the top here is the p16 positive patients and across
both studies, and I'll show you individual studies as well.
But you see all the PRs except this one, which I'll talk about in a
second, were p16 positive. In addition, when
tumors were p16 positive, but the patients did not attain a partial
response, they still derived clinical benefit and had
usually a stable disease with only a couple or a handful that had progressive
disease that were still p16 positive.
On the other hand, p16 negative were
concentrated for progressive disease.
And in fact, there was only a single PR or a partial response in the
p16 negative cohort. What that tells us is that the
p16 staining and the RB hypothesis might be
a candidate to select or enrich for responders, but
also equally important, exclude patients who we think are not going to derive
any benefit or meaningful benefit from the drug.
So this one patient here, just to avoid any confusion, on their first
scan had progressive disease elsewhere, not in their target lesion.
So even though they look like they shrunk, that was actually a progressive disease
case. This one partial response was interesting in
the sense that this patient had a mixed histology,
and they were obviously biomarker negative by our pre-specified criteria.
But the high-grade serous component had also high levels of p16.
So even though it was technically biomarker negative, the high-grade
serous component from this mixed histology fit the hypothesis
as well. Oops, sorry. This study
was done in a staged fashion. So first it was done on the savolnisib-treated
patients.
And what we see here also is p16 positivity heavily enriches
for responders and also those that didn't achieve a partial
response still derive the clinical benefit with stable disease.
And another theme here is we're seeing it across dose levels.
So once you find the sensitive patients,
dose doesn't seem to be as critical and in fact in a multivariable analysis,
there was no difference between the doses.
And in fact, the preclinical hypothesis for both drugs suggested that the lowest
dose in these expansion cohorts was significantly
above the AUC threshold target that needed to be achieved,
which also fits. So it's just a matter of finding the sensitive patients,
the classic biomarker conundrum.
This is the same exact study in VLS-1488.
We see significant enrichment for responders
in the p16 positive and only that one exception,
PR in the p16 negative that I told you about.
And the same exact story, you're seeing responses across dose levels.
It is no surprise when you enrich for response that you see significant PFS
benefit. On the left here is the PFS benefit in p16
positive and negative with patients treated with VLS-1488
approximately six months or so, you see the exact stats
for the p16. Again, this is a retrospective analysis, but it's
obviously important. And in a p16 negative, most of the
patients progress probably at 50 days, which is basically their first scan.
And with the savolnisib-treated patients, you see the exact same pattern,
significant PFS separation between p16 positive
and negative cases. What I'll mention is on its own
in ovarian cancer, p16 is not prognostic.
In other words, we're not treating patients who are going to do better anyway.
That's important to keep in mind.
And actually in other tumor types like endometrial, it's associated with poor
prognosis because it picks up the copy number high endometrial tumors
like serous and carcinosarcomas that usually have a worse prognosis than
other endometrioid histologies.So with that, I'm just going to thank
a lot of people who contributed to this work and happy to take any
questions. Thank you. Thank you all for your attention.
Thank you so much for a fantastic presentation, Sam.
I have a question about your STING story.
So
cancers are not just composed of cancer cells, right?
There are other immune cells in there, and one of the appeals of the
STING agonist was that-
Yeah
... they're going to stimulate these immune cells, which clearly didn't
work. So the question is, so what is happening to
these immune cells, like antigen-presenting cells?
I
guess, is the chronic cGAS stimulation cancer cells also inducing
tachyphylaxis in immune cells in the microenvironment or is there something else
that's happening?
Yeah. Excellent question. And of course, the biology is always a little bit more
complicated.
So there's a part that I didn't talk about, the study that we did, as you may
be aware, is EMPP1, which is an extracellular hydrolase,
that when cancer cells are producing cGAMP,
they pump it outside of the cell into the microenvironment, and that's broken up by
EMPP1 into AMP, and then CD73 or NT5E breaks
that down into adenosine. And adenosine, as you know, is a strong immune
suppressor. So it's not that STING is not
needed in the host. You need it, ideally.
But if you're getting M2 macrophages, they're not going to respond or-- I'm sorry,
M2 like, how are immune suppressive macros--
Basically, if you have an immune suppressive TME, it will not respond as well to
STING agonist as if you have it more primed.
So I think it actually might explain that.
And actually, one of the interesting thing is in early stage
tumor formation, there is a
lesion called a STIC lesion. That is, as you know, is equivalent to DCIS in breast
cancer. And in these STICs, if you see cGAS positive micronuclei, there is a
ton of lymphocytes surrounding them.
So there's probably immune editing going on or an innate immune activation.
And then what happens is eventually the tumors figure a way to suppress interferon,
and in these advanced tumors, whenever you see cGAS positive micronuclei, you see
EMPP1. So what's happening is these are probably adenosine-producing
factories, really. Yeah. It's a great question.
Thank you.
I have a question also about cGAS/STING part.
Sure.
So when chronically treat cells with STING
agonist, it triggers ER stress, but also STING
level can be
decreased.
Yeah.
And when you use cGAS inhibitor, now cause cGAS STING protein
upregulated and also maybe the ER stress is recovered.
How can you tell,
is it only the STING expression level is restored,
drives interferon responses, or is it the ER stress really
playing the role in?
Yeah, it's a good question. I think it's probably both.
My guess is the interferon is probably the most important.
So alleviating ER stress alone is not going to be enough if you're not making
interferon. But to test this formally, I think we would have to use one of the
selective separation of function mutants that Ashley's lab is
generating.
We haven't done that, but yeah. My guess is, you see a
switch, so you restore interferon, and you lose your stress. Yeah.
Thank you.
It's a great question. Yeah.
Hi. Thank you for a very nice talk.
Sure.
You've showed us that
chronic activation from the cGAS-STING pathway eventually leads to
desensitization of STING.
Yeah.
And that eventually we could leverage cGAS inhibition to
resensitize STING to whatever is happening in the tumor.
But then there's something that I fail to understand, probably due to my ignorance
of the pathway.
No. Yeah.
Is that if we manage to inhibit
cGAS and then resensitize STING
to whatever stimuli we plan to use to
generate IFN upregulation, then how do you know that you're not going to
desensitize it again?
Yeah. That's a great question. So I think it's all going to be at the
dosing schedule. I would never
recommend inhibiting cGAS and then giving a STING agonist every day.
Yeah.
Because you're just basically doing what cancer micronuclei are doing
anyway. And STING doesn't need to be constantly
activated. It's not like a kinase inhibitor mode, like where you have to
protect your trough and all these things.
STING just needs to be activated in a pulsatile fashion to initiate immune
responses. And so, I don't know the optimal schedule in humans.
That is a question that needs to be answered clinically, but I would guess maybe
once a week.
This has to be done properly exactly to avoid
chronic activation after you just tried to fix that.
Okay. Thank you.
You're welcome.
I have two questions. The first question, there are different types of chromosomal
instability mentioned.
What is the best way to capture all of them?
Like, if you want to go to clinic, how do you capture all of this in
one way?
We could spend an hour talking about that.
Chromosomal instability, as Uri and Ashley
mentioned, it's a process of ongoing missegregation of chromosomes.
So there's so many different ways to look at it, and it gives you different
facets of that, of flavors. So
doing bulk
DNA sequencing, for example, will give you kind of a bulk level of aneuploidy, but
it won't give you the heterogeneity.
Single-cell DNA sequencing will give you better insight into the heterogeneity.
I
tend to like, if you're asking me, maybe I'm a little bit old
school or low tech, but staining for micronuclei is
actually a very good approach. Because what happens is
micronuclei-Don't live forever.
Cells make micronuclei when they divide, and these micronuclei can get
reintegrated the next mitosis, or they can kind of get degraded over
time. So when you take a tumor and snapshot,
basically put it in FFPE or whatever, and look at
micronuclei, it's giving you a snapshot of what happened in the
prior one to two cell divisions. And looking at the ratio of
micronuclei to primary nuclei probably gives you a good sense.
And this is agnostic to whether it's a chromosome arm or a whole
chromosome. You'll see it in HRD tumors.
You'll see it in homologous recombination proficient tumors.
So it's a good kind of broad capture.
The other option is to looking at mitotic figures in H&E, but that's more
laborious.
Yeah.
My second question is,
for the cGAS-STING, this replication stress inhibitors like
PARP or like KYF18,
there are publications coming out showing that they activate the cGAS-STING
or that pathway, and that's how that mode of action is.
But here now I'm hearing that this is causing the opposite
of that. So is it like you need a certain level of DNA
damage or certain thing that now it gets reactivated, now
the type 1 interferon gamma is going up?
Yeah. I think that DNA damage can activate
cGAS-STING. There's no question, right?
The question is, is it acute strong DNA damage or is it kind of
smoldering, right? I don't think there's a
fundamental difference between our very simple experiments of giving the tumors
cGAMP on day one, day two, day three.
It's just that's kind of like DNA damage can phenocopy that,
but it has important implications.
So for example, I'm a radiation oncologist.
If we give a small dose of radiation to a patient every single day,
maybe we're sensitizing the pathway or desensitizing the STING
pathway, and maybe hypofractionation can be a way to
very strongly activate the STING pathway in tumors.
Again, I'm not arguing that this is the only mechanism, but when it comes to the
pathway, this is an important component.
There's been a lot of
work on PARP inhibitors and STING activation.
I
would like to see that in the clinic at some point.
But I think if we don't deal with acute activation, we may not harness
the effect that we're hoping for.
Thank you.
You're welcome. Okay, great. Just sorry.
One last question. Thank you so much.
Yeah. I have a question regarding p16 staining as a biomarker.
Yeah.
With several tumors, they have homozygous deletion of CDKN2A.
And they have also inactivation of RB.
So that shouldn't work then, right?
Yeah. So this is a really good point.
In GYN malignancies, CDKN2A deep deletion is quite rare.
It's actually about 3% or so. So it's an acceptable false
negative result. In tumors that have very high levels of deep deletion
of CDKN2A, the approach would be to do genome sequencing first,
and if it's not deleted, you do the p16. If it's deleted, you don't do it.
No, that's a really good question. Thank you.
Okay, thank you all for your great discussion and contributions in
coming here today. Thank you.